[Applaus]
willkommen im neuen blog heute passiert
auf jeden fall mega viel und zwar ich
habe einen zahnarzttermin ja und das war
es auf jeden fall comeback von lukas
stadt möchte erstmal wir besprechen
neuesten muster von einem rooney der am
9 9 in den shop kommen soll allerdings
habe ich bis dahin auf jeden fall
erstmal noch zeit um herauszufinden was
[Musik]
fragt einfach nicht ins herz termin
hatten ihr seid ihr dann auch immer so
voll im terminplan der höhe ist aber
beim zahnarzt am so 18 verdient sich
jeden zweiten tag bin ich der einzige
wir machten einen wunsch viel wasser mit
lakritz geschmack denn ich habe den
termin in vor drei minuten ich laufe zum
zahnarzt einfach angezogen
der größte kakao
[Musik]
ich gehe zum zahnarzt und sage was hast
du denn dort findet basel stuhl sieht er
aus wie ein zahn
aber ich wollte doch wird sagen das
nicht gerade beim zahnarzt war beim
zahnarzt hier in den euro sagte schult
vom zahnarzt ich muss auf jeden fall
erstmal noch was essen heute
[Musik]
jetzt sogar das wetter ist werde ich
mich jetzt wissen nach draußen und
arbeite an meinem ten so schön
eingecremt und jetzt erstmal abgebaut
werden
[Musik]
die bräune ein bisschen meine
hässlichkeit verdeck nicht weil ich zum
thema was sie auch schon im titel
eingeblendet sehen und zwar geht es
heute um den podcast von sandra wir uns
was jetzt gerade die erste folge online
gegangen
was guckst du so dass das musst du nicht
weißt es darum waren sich bei mir naja
er zurück auf kommando dinger nein mann
du ich kann gar nicht wissen
machen wir doch mal hier mit kakaobutter
und ich haben uns vor einem monat
hingesetzt haben uns einfach gedacht wir
lagern jetzt einfach für eine
dreiviertelstunde über gott und die welt
das habe dann selbstverständlich
ausgenommen die erste folge ist online
gegangen auf spotify apple music dieser
keine ahnung überall da wo man podcast
hören kann und eigentlich sollte es
andere heute nach köln kommen so dass
wir ein cooles promovideo für die polkas
drehen wir haben uns zwei drei ideen
überlegen wie das cool sagen können von
mm dick und doof also dick weil sandra
ist dick und doof ich bin doch das ist
der name von podcast sie konnten heute
noch köln vom tristen gutes video
zusammen aufnehmen und einfach sagen
leute die erste folge von unserem
podcast ist soeben online gegangen heute
ihr euch doch gern mal an der linke ist
bei der wm in der beschreibung passt
allerdings sich hier weil sie im
krankenhaus ist sie hat irgendwas am
blinddarm unter magen- und irgendwie
galle dann aber auf jeden fall eine
videobotschaft für euch hier kannst du
mir wird gesagt mein blinddarm
ausgenommen
ich weiß nicht wie lange ich noch hier
bin aber unseren podcast gucken auf
jeden fall gerade nicht hier ist und
euch nicht gemeinsam mit mir sagen kann
hey leute unsere erste folge dick und
doof von unserem podcast online gegangen
das jetzt allein weil man da habe ich
auch nicht rechter fuß was geht bei dir
heute so ich höre mir gleich erstmal die
erste folge podcasting und durst mit
sandra und luca euro geben da ist johann
link ist auch hier im video unten der
beschreibung des promo er war das kurz
die immobilientage ein besonderer
nächsten menschen die einfach sehr gerne
alles mögliche aber noch wir können uns
auch über ein themen haben
beispielsweise ersten können wir uns
gefühlt drei tage lang unterhalten und
darüber kaputt lache auf jeden fall
nicht an sandra gesagt egal ich bestelle
mich jetzt hier ein zweites micro ich
habe da vorne ist das habe ich mir noch
ein zweites gestellt und haben uns hier
letztes hingesetzt wird zwei monaten und
haben einfach soll gelabert wir haben
einfach nur gelabert und das sind zwei
folgen bei rumgekommen also die ersten
zwei folgen podcast schon aufgenommen
die wir jetzt gesagt ist die erste folge
jetzt gerade so eben online gegangen
überall wo es podcast zu hören gibt
spotify have been using keine ahnung was
m und die werden jetzt jede woche also
wöchentlich donnerstags um 18 uhr kommt
eine neue folge wie sandra und ich nicht
so wie andere podcast irgendwie jetzt
über das politikgeschehen oder die
wettervorhersage laden oder so sondern
einfach über schwarzen lachen uns kaputt
und lagern einfach über schwachsinn also
wenn ihr braucht euch das ganze mal zu
hören
wie beim ein- oder beim autofahren oder
keine ahnung was dann geht auf jeden
fall mal die unter dem video die wir
beschreibungen clique den link an dann
kommt er daher zu unserem podcast
und ja das wollte ich eigentlich nur
sagen und ich geh jetzt erst mal kacken
kranken ist unspannend
es sind mittlerweile zwei stunden
vergangen ich bin mir gerade am videos
schneiden vorproduzieren für einen
urlaub weil wenn ich diesen blog ja auch
gerade sich mitschüler an der nordsee
ein bisschen urlaub machen aber ihr
wisst ja dass das thema privatsphäre mir
sehr wichtig ist und hier standen auch
schon öfters mal zuschauer im
treppenhaus oder im innenhof oder
irgendwie so und das geht halt einfach
zu weit was hier allerdings gerade vor
sich gegangen ist das ist ich erzähle
sollte mal wie bereits gesagt er ist
ganz friedlich an meinem pc schneide
meine videos produziert die vorführen
und auf einmal kommt mein größter fan
ist hauptsächlich einfach etwas fällt
die einzigartig wahnsinnig bei sowas und
die hollies kommen übrigens am 9.9 luca
chance nun und ich sind jetzt im gym
angekommen lula hat jetzt einen trainer
termin oder trainieren schon leute und
ich trainierte team war super ich nicht
das zweite mal 1 1 gestanden
jetzt bitte nicht erschrecken freunde
aber ich mache gerade eine gesichtsmaske
nur wenige minuten später ich kann nicht
mehr sprechen
heute ist allerdings auch beenden oder
lieben freunde von fast einer treppe
gefallen wenn ich dafür auch heute
gefeiert hat das gerne einen daumen hoch
unter dem video hier da schreibt man die
kommentare ob ich mehr locken soll
die sache ist haltbarer ist es meine
haut gerade rot wegen der maske die
sache ist halt das in meinem leben immer
die so viel vor sich geht ist für die
meiste zeit eigentlich wirklich nur
allein zu hause aber vielleicht wollte
er dennoch mehr boxen und in der video
beschreibung ist auf jeden fall alles
verlinkt zum podcast
da könnte ja gern mal reinschauen und
abonniert auch die am main kanal
verletzt noch keine linux bereit
[Musik]